para el gobierno pakistaní los discursos
de imran khan han perturbado la paz lo
que ha llevado a la policía a presentar
cargos de terrorismo contra el el sábado
como ha sido costumbre desde que fue
detenido en abril el ex primer ministro
reunió a miles de partidarios y
pronunció un fuerte discurso que para la
policía paquistaní representó una
amenaza hacia ellos y el magisterio
[Aplausos]
el inspector general de la policía de
islamabad y el subdirector general y no
los perdonaré os presentaremos una
demanda contra ustedes y contra la
magistrada sebas audrey también deberían
prepararse deberían avergonzarse de lo
que han hecho
khan un populista carismático y antigua
estrella del cricket fue elegido en 2018
aparentemente con la ayuda de los
poderosos militares de pakistán pero el
pasado mes de abril tras una votación
parlamentaria de censura fue destituido
en medio de un creciente enfado por la
alta inflación y un supuesto
desencuentro con los militares desde que
el tribunal supremo confirmó la
destitución kahn se ha propuesto
demostrar que sigue siendo una fuerza
poderosa y está funcionando su partido
político ha tenido éxito en las
recientes elecciones locales icann en su
regreso ha traído a decenas de miles de
personas en lo que parece ser una
creciente represión por parte del
gobierno la autoridad de medios de
comunicación de pakistán prohibió la
transmisión en vivo de los discursos de
khan el ex primer ministro contra atacó
en las redes sociales
les acusó de bloquear el acceso a
youtube donde había prometido salir en
directo en cientos de canales
can también afirmó que la policía
torturo a un aliado cercano que fue
detenido por cargos de sedición
kan se arriesga a pasar varios años en
prisión